your son had a second birthday party and
you posted a picture of the birthday
party and it's the coolest mom and her
sign picture the only time in my life
that I've wanted to be at a child's
birthday party though we we did do the
kid birthday party first right where we
did like the trains and the jumping cat
and all that kind of stuff and then I
was like you know what it's I popped him
out so it's kind of I get to celebrate
that part - sure no so it was a it was a
twofer
that's fantastic now have the birthday
parties change to something that's a
couple of years ago was that the only
time there's been a bikinis and all your
friends come over and yeah a party yeah
now I think that he's getting to an age
where maybe we need to settle down a
little bit because I mean he's the naked
one now and that's fine okay what's he
like what's your son like my son is he's
a little ham and he is really he's got
some really crazy ideas nowadays
yesterday I was in his bedroom and
getting all his clothes ready - for
school and he went into the bathroom
when he came back out and he goes mama
what day is it I go it's Monday he goes
yeah I only shake my paper on Wednesdays
and Fridays like who are we talking like
strip club area what's happening
shame is people yeah so apparently you
know I told him to shank after I think I
don't know I you shake after don't ya
you put your hands above your head and
you
talk to me
you probably does the twirling on
Mondays yes we have it down to Tuesday
and no Wednesdays and Fridays Wednesdays
and Fridays oh okay
wow that's so he had apparently
forgotten to shake I'm sure so what's
okay so I just love that he's come to
ease come down to this like there's got
to be a system you can't do it every
time no no it's just too much work
Wow and and he uses the word people yes
now that was that was a friend of mine
who called it that and it's stuck and so
it's kind of cute I mean not everyone
knows what it is I've we have I have a
goddaughter who he's obsessed with who's
eight and he started talking about his
paper this is becoming a thing yeah he
said something about his pin she goes
what's a paper and he pulls his pants
down and shoves it right in there
because this is a deeper and it's so
innocent cuz he's not even old
yeah he needs to get help right away
you